TODD KERPELMAN: Hello
game developers,
and thank you for joining me in
this very special presentation.
I apologize for
not dressing nicer.
Actually, I have this really
nice shirt that my wife just
got me for Christmas
that I was going to wear,
but if you'll notice, it's
kind of the same color
as our green screen background.
And I would be
invisible for most
of the talk, which I guess
I thought at first was cool,
but then decided
would be creepy.
So you get t-shirt Todd.
But that's OK.
I still respect you.
And we're going to jump
right into our talk here.
This presentation is called
Play Games Best Practices.
This is based on a talk that
I gave in November of 2013
at GDCNext, that
was formerly titled
Play Games-- What We've Learned.
I've edited it somewhat,
shortened it for content,
and really focused more on best
practices for implementing Play
Games services, which
I think, hopefully,
you as game developers
will care most about.
So with that in
mind, here we go.
So when we talk
about, Play Games,
what I'm really here
to talk about today
is two aspects of Play Games.
First would be the set
of mobile gaming services
that we launched at Google
I/O. These include features
like achievements, leaderboards,
Cloud Save, and multi-player.
This also includes the Play
Games standalone application.
If you've tuned into
this presentation
because you're hoping to
hear like the five ways
to hack the Google Play Store
to get on to the top most
recent list, this
is not that talk,
and you're going to be
somewhat disappointed.
Just to give you a little
history of these services,
Play Games launched
at Google I/O of 2013,
which means they are about
eight months old as of maybe
next week.
We started with about
24 games at launch.
I think at this point we have
well over 2,000 games that
have integrated game services.
And these games
are available both
on iOS-- here you can see
some achievements on the iOS
version of Stickman Gun Fu,
I believe-- and on Android.
And here we can see
some lovely achievements
for Triple Town, one
of my favorite games.
The Play Games app
launched the standalone app
in July of 2013,
which means it's
about six months old
as of this recording.
So happy half-birthday,
Play Games standalone app.
I don't have official numbers
to share with you right now,
but if you go to the
Play store and you
look at the
application, you'll see
it's in the 10 to 50
million installs category.
So hopefully that will
give you a rough idea
of the number of people who
have this thing installed,
with a margin of error of plus
or minus 20 million, I guess.
The point of all these
stats, by the way,
is not to cheerlead,
and to not say, oh, wow,
look how great we are.
It's really just to show
you that at this point,
we feel like we have enough
information from all the people
using the Play Games app,
from all the developers
that have implemented
game services,
that we feel like some
patterns have emerged--
some very sexy patterns.
And we feel like we now
have enough information
to give you some best practices
to kind of improve your games
and make them the best that
they can be using our platform.
So with that, let's start
by talking about sign-in.
So this is a tale of two sign-in
flows, one which eventually
leads to a revolution,
but hopefully
without the muskets and the
bloodshed and the decapitation.
So we're going to
start by taking you
through the officially
sanctioned sign-in flow,
as implemented by Riptide
2 GP, by our friends
over at Vector Unit.
So this is the initial
screen that you
might see if you were
to start the game.
There's a little sign in
button there on the left.
But you know, maybe I
choose to ignore that,
and I say, hey, you
know what, I'm just
going to click on
my player profile.
We click on that.
We get into another screen.
The sign-in button
is still there.
But maybe I say,
you know what, I'm
going to go and click on
this achievements button,
and see what my
achievements are.
Well at this point, a dialog
box pops up that says,
hey, would you like to
sign in to Play Games,
because we use that to
track your achievements.
I say, OK, yeah
that sounds good.
An OAuth2 dialogue permission
screen pops up that I look at.
And I say, oh OK,
this makes sense.
I understand why the
game is asking me
for these permissions.
It just said, hey, do
you want to sign in
to track your achievements?
And so I say, this looks good.
I hit sign in.
I get back into the application.
I now see that it has
been personalized.
Over on the upper right there,
you can see my name-- or,
most of my name.
And the sign in button has now
turned into a sign out button.
All in all, this has
been a generally kind
of friendly flow.
I understood at every step of
the way what's been going on.
You know, it's kind of
the warm fuzzy puppy
dog of sign-in flows.
So that's nice.
Now, let's take a look at
a not-so-recommended flow.
This-- I didn't want to call
out any particular partner,
so this is my lovely
made-up game of Eschaton.
The game starts up, and
maybe it kind of loads.
And before I even
get into the game,
before I get into a main
menu or anything like that,
I'm shown this
permissions dialogue.
And at this point,
I don't quite know--
why is it showing me this?
Why is it asking me to sign in?
I don't really understand.
And this, it's a little scary.
It's a little frightening.
And you know, I want my mommy.
So here's our quiz for you.
Which sign-in flow do you think
did better-- the warm fuzzy
puppy dog flow, or the
scary, I want my mommy flow?
Go, raise your hand.
I know this is on YouTube, and
maybe you're at the office.
But you know, put your
hand up behind your head,
as if you were kind of
scratching or something.
Raise your hand if you
said warm puppy dog flow.
That's a fair number of you.
Raise your hand if
you think scary,
I want my mommy flow did better.
That's some of you.
Well, if you thought that the
warm puppy dog flow converted
better, you would be incorrect.
The scary, I want my
mommy flow actually
converted significantly better
than our officially recommended
flow.
And this is a bit of a dilemma,
particularly for you guys
as game developers.
Right like, why be good, why
try and do the right thing,
when you get much
better conversion
by doing the thing
we don't recommend?
And this is kind of your
traditional prisoner's dilemma,
tragedy of the commons,
stuff you probably
learned about in Economics
101 kind of thing.
And so we looked at this.
And the way we saw it,
there were sort of two ways
we could resolve this situation.
One would be simply enforcement.
We could say, hey, you
know this sign-in flow goes
against our best practices,
and if you don't fix it,
we're going to ban
you from the store,
and send our robot
army after you,
and say bad things about
you behind your back.
The thing is, this is
isn't really our style.
We don't like to use the
bandhammer if we don't have to.
And the robot army
is still in beta.
That joke was a little
funnier, more outlandish,
before we went and bought
all those robot companies.
Now, I don't know.
A little close to home.
Anyway, option number
two is hey, maybe,
we should take this
scary and jarring flow,
and just make it a little
less scary and jarring.
So we're doing two things.
First, we're changing our policy
to explicitly allow and even
encourage this type
of sign-in flow.
However, along with
that, rolling out
to Android devices
like, now-- by the time
you see this video-- we're
adding a nice little animation
that's going to let
the user know what's
about to happen, right
before they sign in.
So here's our example again.
Here's our game of Eschaton.
And the game starts up.
And I see the loading bar.
And now this time, look at that.
We got this nice little
animation saying, hey,
we're about to sign you
in to Play Games services.
Right, this is nice.
I have a lot more context now
as to why the game is giving me
this permissions dialogue.
In fact, in some
ways, I actually
think this is a lot better.
With the sign in button,
you didn't actually
know, necessarily, what
you were signing in for.
Right, like was it just
to share posts on Google+?
Was it to remember who I am?
There was nothing about that
button that suggested oh, yeah,
this is for achievements
and leaderboards.
So with this intro
animation, the user suddenly
has a lot more context, and
they understand now what
they're being asked when they
get this permissions dialogue.
So I think it's kind of
a win-win all around.
Your users understand what's
going on a lot better,
and you as developers
hopefully get some better
sign-in conversion.
So all in all, we think
this is a good change.
With that, let's move
on to achievements.
So, the first point I want
to make about achievements
is achievements do matter.
I feel like at some point,
all of us as game developers,
game designers-- we
all got really cynical
about achievements.
You know, we're too
cool for them now.
I don't entirely
know why this is.
My theory is maybe we got
tired of like, all these guys
in suits coming in and
saying things like, hey, I'm
going to add the
gamification to cooking,
and getting a ton of VC funding.
Which actually is
not a bad idea.
If any of you would like to
join my gamification cooking
start up, talk to
me after this video.
But, my point is that
achievements do matter.
Maybe not to all
of your players,
but definitely to some of
them, most likely your hardcore
players.
Right?
The players that
are actually going
to be spending most of their
money in your application.
And so my first recommendation
when it comes to achievements
is, don't phone it in.
I know as developers, you
can spend hundreds of hours
play testing and balancing
all of your game play.
But then don't kind of whip
together the achievements
in the last four
minutes before you ship.
Don't do that.
Think about these
achievements when
you're first
designing your game.
Think about what
achievements would be fun.
So the number one trick
I have to designing
good mobile
achievements is simply
design good achievements.
We sort of went out
onto the internet
and looked at some
of the advice that
was out there about
good achievement design,
and we felt like 90% of
that advice still stands.
If you haven't designed
achievements before,
if you're looking
for where to start,
there's a really good article
on Gamasutra called "Achievement
Design 101" by Greg McClanahan.
I believe he was the community
manager on Kongregate
for quite a number of years.
He designed a lot of
their achievements
in the first few years
of their service.
He wrote this very good article.
I encourage you to check it out.
I'm not going to repeat
all that advice here,
because that would be redundant.
But here's one example
that I really like.
Let's say that there's this
amazing, once in a blue moon
moment that happens in
your game that's awesome.
Somehow, your play
tester manages
to make this amazing, crazy
thing happen in your game,
and you're like, oh my god,
I've never seen that before.
We have to reward
our players if they
can pull off that same maneuver.
And so you add this achievement.
You say, hey here's
this achievement--
pull off this crazy, once
in a lifetime maneuver.
And for your players who, as
they're playing their game,
happen to pull off this
crazy, once in a blue moon
kind of maneuver, it is kind of
nice to get an achievement that
recognizes hey, that thing
you did was really awesome,
and we'd like to
reward you for it.
However, the problem is
the rest of your players--
there's going to be
a lot of them that
are going to try and earn all of
your achievements in your game.
And so what's going
to happen is they
are going to play this level,
try and pull off this once
in a lifetime maneuver, fail,
quit, restart your level.
Try again.
Try and pull off
this crazy maneuver.
Fail.
Quit.
Restart, and restart,
and restart, and restart,
until after a few hundred
repeats of gameplay,
they can finally pull off this
crazy, once in a blue moon
type of maneuver.
And when that
happens, the reaction
is not going to be, oh
my god, that was awesome.
The reaction is
going to be, I'm so
glad to be done with
this stupid thing.
And, by the way, I
hate you, your game,
and everything your
game stands for.
What I do recommend,
by the way, is
if your game does
have moments like this
that you want to show off,
consider capturing replay
and uploading it to
someplace like YouTube.
I mean gameplay is the
second most popular category
on YouTube after music.
People love watching
other people play games.
And if you're able
to-- it's not trivial.
But if you're able
to kind of keep
a running total, or a running
record of your game's logic
over the last few minutes,
be able to rewind,
record that out to a buffer,
upload that video then
onto YouTube, and allow players
to share it, all of a sudden,
there's an opportunity
now for your game
to be exposed to thousands,
or tens of thousands,
or hundreds of thousands
of people who might not
have otherwise seen
or noticed your game.
So if you do want to reward a
player for this kind of moment,
look into being able to share
replays on a video sharing
site, instead of looking
at an achievement.
A good mobile
achievement should serve
as a guideline for your
players so that there is still
more for them to do.
I think this holds particularly
true in mobile games,
because in general,
a console game still
tends to have more
of the stronger,
single player
narrative experiences.
No one is playing BioShock
and they get to this moment
here where Elizabeth clocks them
with the book and says, well,
I guess I'm done.
Put down the controller, let
me find something else to play.
This doesn't happen, because
there's very clearly something
in the narrative that is
dragging the player forward,
that is letting them know, no,
there's definitely more for you
to do here in this game.
By contrast, let's
look at a game
like Plague Inc. By the time
I'm done playing this game,
and maybe I've infected
the world, am I done?
Is there more for me
to do in this game?
Maybe I can play on a
harder difficulty level.
But maybe I also think
that I've seen everything
there is to see in this
game, and I uninstall it.
I think this is an example
where Plauge Inc. In particular
did a really good job
with their achievements.
If you look at their
list of achievements,
you can see that there's a
lot of depth to this game
that a player who's only playing
it the first or second time
around might not realize.
You look at some of the
achievements on this list,
and it's like, you can cause
World War III to break out.
Or you can infect astronauts
before they go to the moon,
and all of a sudden,
you can infect space.
Or you can cause a zombie
outbreak to happen.
This is all stuff
that I as a player
might not realize if I were to
just casually play this game.
Now all of a sudden,
I see this stuff,
I'm compelled to try and pull
off more of these goals here.
And I suddenly discover
there's a much deeper aspect
to this game than I might
have otherwise realized.
So if your game has
these kind of elements,
if your game has
a layer of depth
that you want to make sure
your players know about,
use an achievement to
kind of guide them there.
When it comes to
mobile achievements,
do remember that you're
on a mobile device,
and users can be
interrupted at any moment.
Watch out for achievements
that require your user
to do something in one
sitting, or watch out for,
hey, do this thing
in under 60 seconds.
At the very least,
make sure that you're
pausing your achievement
timer if your game has
to go into the background,
or your user suddenly
receives a phone call.
This is not a major
issue I've seen
with most mobile developers.
They kind of understand the
context of mobile games.
But if you are porting your
game over from another platform,
if you're porting it
over from console, look
at your achievements,
make sure they still
stand up in this
kind of environment.
And don't forget that
your game is expanding.
Don't forget to add
new achievements
when you add new content.
Maybe seems obvious, but I've
seen some developers miss this.
You've got three
worlds in your game,
and you're game goes out there.
And it turns out
it's a massive hit.
And you're like, whoa, we've
got to keep adding stuff
to this game so that
players keep playing it,
and keep talking
about it, and keep
buying in-game items,
and all of that.
And so you go ahead and you
add more levels to your game.
Well remember,
achievements serve
as a guidepost to your
player that there's still
more for them to do.
And so add in some
achievements to accompany
this extra content.
And finally, watch out for
what I call the achievement
avalanche.
I have seen a lot
of games do this.
Let's say we've got ourselves
a little puzzle game.
And we decide all
right, well, we'll
add some achievements
for completing
various levels along the way.
This is fine, totally
standard, it works.
And then we say,
we should also add
some kind of challenge
type of achievements.
You know, like can
you finish a game,
or finish a level in
under three minutes?
And can you finish a
level without dying,
or without using an undo?
This seems all like
a really good idea.
Seems like we've sort of
got a nice mix of progress
achievements and
challenge-type achievements.
But who can see
the problem here?
Raise your hand.
OK, a couple of you.
I see you out there
in YouTube land.
Here's the issue.
I play the game, and
I complete level one,
and I get an achievement for if.
The kicker is, level
one was probably
the easiest level
in the entire game.
And so there's a
very good chance
that not only have I
completed level one,
but I have now completed a level
without dying, without using
any undos, in under
three minutes,
and I've gotten a
three star score.
And blammo, sort of before I've
gotten the chance, as a player,
to get invested at
all in your game,
all the interesting
achievements are gone.
These are all used up.
And maybe it's kind of
nice having that moment
after the first level where
I get five achievements,
but I'm not invested enough in
your game yet, at this point,
to care.
And then there's not
much left to keep
me interested after that.
So watch out for these
types of achievements.
If it seems like there's a
good chance you'll give away
half your achievements
in the first level,
find other ways to reward those
same types of achievements.
So with that, let's
get into leaderboards.
And here the best piece
of advice I can give you
is keep your leaderboards clean.
Leaderboards can
be a fantastic way
to build community
around your game.
People start to compete.
They decide to check out
the weekly leaderboard
and see how they're doing.
And they come back and
make sure they're still
somewhere in the top of
their weekly leaderboard,
or their social leaderboard
among their friends.
If you have a good
leaderboard system going,
it can be inexpensive and really
easy retention for your game.
So imagine how
disheartening it can
be for one of your top players
if they get a score that they
think has got to make the
top five all time scores,
they check out
their leaderboard,
and they see this-- oh,
look, the top layer here
has [INAUDIBLE].
Well, that can be
really disheartening.
And this happens enough
times, players sort of
get disillusioned,
and they no longer
care about your leaderboards.
And the fact of matter
is, at the end of the day,
leaderboard board data
generated by your game client
is never going to be
completely trustworthy.
But there are things you can
do to help mitigate this.
First, kind of a quick and
easy solution-- set limits.
Not all games have a
theoretical maximum.
But if you do, add those
into the leaderboards.
Make sure the
leaderboard rejects
any score that is
theoretically impossible.
At the very least, it just
kind of makes them look better.
This can help, but
obviously not all games
have theoretical limits.
Maybe yours doesn't.
So the other option I would
encourage you to look at
is players.hide.
This is a REST call, this is
one of our management calls,
that hides any player from
the public leaderboard.
This can also be kind of sneaky
in that it hides the player
from everybody but
him or herself.
So the cheating player
doesn't actually
know that they've been
hidden unless they
were to find a friend
playing the same game
and ask their friend to go
and check the high score list
and look for them.
And then they find out
that they've been hidden.
And maybe if they're a cheater,
they don't have any friends.
So I would encourage you
to look at players.hide
to hide any players that
very obviously don't
have legitimate scores.
The REST call is out there.
It's well documented.
The actual documentation is
not in perspective like this.
It's just normal, readable.
We also have a
sample application
that you can download
that will make it easier
for you to make these calls.
It's called, I believe,
management tools.
And it's available
from our github page.
So drop on by your github page.
Check it out.
And then finally, we just
recently added score tags.
And this is a string of up
to 64 URI-safe characters
that you can submit
along with your score
when they get sent
to our servers.
And this could be used in
a number of different ways.
Some of it might just be
for analytics information.
You're curious what
level a player was
on when they submitted
this amazing score.
But you can also use it for
things like adding a hash.
You can kind of make some
hash of the user's score
as sort of a way to verify
that their score actually
seems somewhat legitimate.
Or, if your game server happens
to be the ultimate recorder
of truth, add a link to
the entry on your server
that confirms that
yes, this score
that this player
submitted is legitimate.
It's what the
server thinks it is.
And you can kind of
start to combine this
with the players.hide call that
we had in the previous slide
to make your own custom
anti-cheating script.
So you can make a script that
makes this scores.list call,
gets a whole bunch
of these scores,
and starts analyzing them--
going through each one
and saying, all right, looking
at this score and score
tag that's with it, does
this seem legitimate?
And if it doesn't,
call players.hide.
Hide that player, go back, and
go through your next score.
And if you start running
this kind of script
on a regular basis,
you can start
to get really efficient with
your leaderboard cleaning.
You can get your con ops person,
your customer support person,
to run this once or twice a day.
And suddenly you have
some leaderboards
that once again look legitimate
and can kind of bring
on that type of
retention you get
with a good leaderboard system.
And so with this, we're going
to move on to multi-player.
And I should probably
make it clear here
that what we're
really talking about
right now is real
time multi-player.
Turn-based multi-player has
just been announced and launched
within a day or
two of this video.
We don't have enough information
yet to give you best practices.
But when it comes to
real time multi-player,
the biggest thing we learned
is matchmaking is really hard.
So be glad you
don't have to do it.
Here's what we discovered.
So in a traditional
client server set up,
you've got your
desktop computer,
and it's going out, and
pinging a list of known servers
out there in the world.
And finds the one that seems
have the best ping time,
and suggests, hey, maybe this
is the server you want to join.
And that works fine in
a client-server set up.
However, with real time
games using Games services,
we're using a
peer-to-peer network.
And you can't ping every
other phone in the world.
Partly because there
is a lot of them.
And partly because they're just
not really set up that way.
The only way to really
know about another client
is to connect with them.
And at that point,
it's kind of too late
if it turns out it's
a bad connection.
And maybe you didn't want
to connect with them.
You kind of have to write
it out at that point.
However, we can start to learn.
So for instance,
we might discover
that a number of devices--
maybe it seems like they're
in the same general
area, geographically,
and therefore are likely to
connect well with each other.
We can get more
sophisticated than that too.
Like we might learn about
different connections
among different devices
in different locations.
And by the way,
all this example--
completely hypothetical.
But let's say we learned that
devices in, say, the Seattle
area and devices in Boise, Idaho
have a really good connection.
Not sure why, they just do.
And maybe we also
learned that-- again, all
hypothetical-- maybe connections
between Seattle and Portland,
they're all getting
routed through Baltimore
for some reason.
And so they're not as good.
And so maybe we'll
start to avoid
trying to connect these
two devices if we can.
And we can start taking this
vast amount of information
that we're getting, and use that
to more intelligently match up
players.
So we've got this
situation where
a player is looking for
opponents to play with.
We start off a little picky.
A player pops up that we
know isn't a good connection,
we might say, hey, you
know what, let's not
connect with them right away.
Let's see if there's maybe
some other players that
would be better for us
to play a game with.
So some time goes on, and we
find a player that we think,
yeah, will connect
well with them.
Maybe another opponent pops up.
We say, yeah, they would
be a good opponent.
It's only after
some time goes on,
and we haven't found
anybody else better,
then we will kind of
lower our standards
and pick a player with a
not as good connection.
And you might be
asking yourself,
why are we doing this?
Why don't we just wait for
somebody better to come along?
Why even make this connection
in the first place?
Well, here's the big
metric-- 12 seconds.
This is the amount
of time at which
players will start
to abandon your game.
They'll start to get
impatient and say, eh, I
didn't want to play
this game after all.
So we want to do
our best to match up
the majority of our players
before we hit that point, based
on the idea that any game is
better than an abandoned game.
And so the first piece
of advice I can give you
is that if you want a really
successful multi-player game,
you'd start by having a very
successful multi-player game.
You want a game with millions
of people all playing it,
at all times, the idea being
that if there are millions
of users out there,
all looking to play,
we have a very rich
pool from which
we can pull really good
multi-player candidates.
Which, I know is not
very actionable advice.
You're probably
already trying to make
a successful multi-player game.
So let's look at maybe a more
practical recommendation, which
is keep variants to a minimum.
We have this feature
that is very powerful.
We let you select what
type of multi-player game
you want to join before
you even start connecting.
So for instance, you
might decide, hey,
I'm going to add a variant where
people can decide before they
play, do I want to play a
game of capture the flag,
or do I want to play a game of
team death match or conquest?
And players will
only get matched up
with other players looking
to play the same type of game
as them.
Again, powerful feature, right?
But there's a downside to it.
Let's say we have this
full complement of users.
And you say, OK, well you know
I'm going to add a variant.
I want to let players
decide whether they're
going to play death match
or capture the flag.
Well, just by doing
that, you've divided
this pool of potential
players in half.
And then you say to
yourself, oh, well, I also
want to have a variant for
whether friendly fire is
turned on or off.
And we should
probably let players
decide if they want to play a
three, five, or seven minute
game.
Oh, and you know what?
Of course we want a
newbies-only room,
so that beginning players
don't feel overwhelmed
when they first start the game.
Well, now, all of
a sudden, we've
got nobody around
that wants to play
the same newbies-only, seven
minute, friendly fire on,
capture the flag game as
our initial player, who's
looking for opponents.
And maybe we don't find
anybody for them to match with,
and they end up
abandoning the game.
And that's sad for all of us.
So how do we fix this?
My recommendation
would be that if you
think all of these
options that you
have variants for-- if you
think they're all nice,
but not deal breakers, like if
you think players wouldn't mind
playing a friendly fire game
even if they prefer it off--
then create auto-matching
with no variants,
or as few variants as possible.
That will bring up as
many potential candidates
for us to match up
your players with.
Then, once your
players have joined
and we find people that
seem to have good network
connections for each
other, then bring up
a UI that lets players
vote on what type of game
they want to play.
Not everyone's going to
get what they voted for.
A majority is
going to rule here.
But if you think these options
are all sort of nice-to-haves
and not deal
breakers, leave them
as something players can vote on
after they've been matched up.
So let's move on to another
aspect of multi-player games,
and that's invitations.
So we have this system.
We have a bunch of built-in
UI that allows your player
to invite specific
friends to play with them.
But here's one thing
we discovered--
and again, real
time multi-player
only-- the vast
majority of people
don't send out
invitations to friends
unless they're all in
the same room already.
Or, I guess in this case, the
same park where they are all
dressed formally, because it's
one of those formal parks.
And the reason is, when you send
off the invitation to a friend,
you don't know what
their situation.
I mean, are they sitting
at home watching TV,
and happy to be interrupted?
Are they sitting at
the movies and don't
want to get your game invite?
Are they playing a game on
their phone already and happy
to receive other invitations?
Are they taking a
serious phone call
and don't want to
get interrupted?
Your inviting
player doesn't know.
You don't know as a developer.
And frankly, neither do we.
From a technical perspective,
I have my phone in my pocket
and I'm bored versus I
have my phone in my pocket
and I don't want to
be interrupted looks
very much the same.
And remember, you only have 12
seconds for this other person
to take the phone out of
their pocket see the invite,
make a decision as to whether
they want to join this game
or not before your original
player gets impatient.
And so what we've discovered
is the vast majority
of your games, like 95% of your
games, are using auto-match.
This is the flow
where basically I say,
I don't care who I
get matched up with.
Just match me up with an
opponent as soon as possible.
And so you should do your best
to encourage this type of flow
in a real-time
multi-player game.
And so that means you start by
adding a quick match button.
This should be a button
that's sort of one click, zero
dialogues to get into
a multi-player game.
And while you're at
it, make this button
the obvious default.
Have the invite
friends button there,
some people if they are
gathered in the same room
as their friends will want
to play a multi-player game
with them.
But make the quick match
the easy to find default.
This would be the
code for doing it.
I'm not going to go over this
too much, because this is all
available in our
sample documentation,
so check that out.
And so with that, let's move
into our lightning round--
a few other little
best practices
that I wanted to talk about.
First, use diverse icons
for your achievements
in leaderboards.
So let's go back to
our Play Games app.
Remember I said it had 10
to 50 million installs?
I want to point out, these
are voluntary installs.
These are people-- this doesn't
count the app being preloaded
on devices, which it
also is for some devices.
This is people that have
gone to the Play store,
found the Play Games
app, and said, yes, I
want to download this thing.
So you've got some
hard core game
players that are using
the Play Games app.
And you're going to start to
get a not insignificant number
of installs that come
from this application.
So you want to make sure
that your app is well
represented in here.
And there are three
things when people say,
I want to see what games
my friends are playing.
I want to see what games are
recommended in the Play Games
app.
They're going to bring up
this entry about your game.
And there's three things
they're going to see.
First is going to be
your game's description.
Next is going to be a list
of achievements in your game.
And the third is going to be
your list of leaderboards.
And what we
recommend here is you
want to use some really
nice diverse icons here
so that your game displays
well in this type of situation.
So if we take a look
at Triple Town here,
they've got they got a
pretty good set of icons.
They're different.
They're kind of cute.
They're fun.
They're within the
style of the game.
They look fun.
They might make me
say, hey, this game
kind of looks like fun.
Maybe I will check it out.
Don't be this guy.
Sorry Nostalgic Racer,
I'm going to pick on you.
Notice how all the
achievement icons
are just the same version
of their game icon, that's
repeated right there
on the upper left.
This looks a lot less
interesting, I think,
to a potential player.
Just visually, it doesn't
have that same kind of oomph.
And for crying
out loud, don't do
what this developer
did, and just put
a bunch of secret achievements.
No one looks at that
and says, oh man, I
can't wait to try out this
game with a few achievements
that I don't know what they are.
Secret achievements
really should only
be used if you've got
spoilers in your game
and you don't want players
to find out about them.
Otherwise, this does
nothing to draw a player in.
So remember, this is kind of
your game's representation
in the Play Games app.
You've probably spent 40
iterations tweaking your game's
icon to make sure it looks
good in the Play store.
Don't then kind of ignore
your game's representation
in the Play Games app.
And by the way, all this advice
goes double for leaderboards,
because leaderboards are
always going to show up.
One, they're always going
to show up in color,
because unlike achievements,
leaderboards are always earned.
And I think developers
often overlook this,
because they forget that
leaderboard icons can also
be displayed to the user.
Check your alerts in the Google
Play Developer console, also
known as mistakes your
game is probably making.
There are few situations
where your game is probably
running into trouble, and you
as a developer won't realize it.
One of the most
common ones is if you
were to add a new achievement or
a new leaderboard to your game,
and you forget to
publish that leaderboard
within the developer console.
You get a warning
that looks like this.
And admittedly, this is a
very weird, tricky scenario.
The idea is, let's say
you add a new high score
list to your game.
There's two things
you need to publish.
First, you need to
publish your client that
attempts to submit scores
to this new leaderboard.
But you also need to publish
the leaderboard itself,
within the game service.
And that's what you would
do through the Play Games
developer console.
And so what will
happen is, if you only
remember to publish the client,
a bunch of your players,
they'll get this new client.
It will attempt to submit
the player's high score
to this leaderboard.
And the Play Games service
will say, wait a minute,
I don't know this leaderboard.
This is a leader board
that hasn't been published.
I'm going to reject this call.
And your players' scores
will get discarded.
And what even makes
this trickier is
that you as a developer
probably don't
see this error, because with
any developer or test accounts,
those can submit
scores to leaderboards
that are not published.
So your players will
complain, hey, you know,
I can't seem to earn
this achievement,
or I can't seem to
get this leaderboard.
You're going to try it out,
and you're going to say,
I don't understand.
It works fine for me.
Yes, this is the little
publishing screen
that you have to remember
to visit as well.
And so really, one of
the best ways for you
to find out about these
types of situations
is to look for any alerts
that you might get.
Get in the habit of
visiting your developer
console on a weekly
basis, and just
make sure there's no alerts
that are popping up there.
Another best practice-- I
implore you to use Cloud Save.
I think Cloud Save was
probably better received
than what some of the folks
on the team had anticipated.
And if you think about
it, it's really basic
compared to a lot of
the other cloud services
that we provide at Google.
All it is it's
just a system that
lets developers save and load
information to the cloud.
And that's kind of it.
But it turns out basic and
simple Cloud Save solution
is really all a lot of
developers really need.
And if you think about
it, this makes sense.
This covers a lot of the
most problematic cases
that players run into.
The biggest being
the hey, I just
got a new device, and
this game that I've
been playing for the last four
months and I'm up at level 30,
I've installed on my new
device and, oh my god,
here I am at level one again.
And I really don't
want to have to go
and unlock those same 30 levels.
Maybe I'll go find
something else to play.
I mean, developers tell us
that they see a drop off
in game play when a user
upgrades their device.
And I am quite sure this is
one of the main reasons why.
No one wants to go and
unlock those same 60
beginning levels
again, just to get
to where they were last time.
This also by the way
helps deal with the hey,
I just uninstalled and
reinstalled my game,
and oh my god, what
happened all my game data?
Is that gone too?
Forget it.
I don't want to play
this game anymore.
I mean, that could be
amazingly disheartening
if you suddenly find
that all your progress is
lost because you either
reinstalled the game,
or because you switched devices.
So, please, please, please, look
at using Cloud Save if you can.
For crying out loud, you don't
even have to use our service.
Use some kind of
cloud save service.
But you know, ours
is pretty good.
So let's review.
First, use the new sign-in flow.
This nice intro animation should
be out to all Android devices
now.
So just send people right
into the OAuth dialogue.
It'll be a much better
experience for them.
Achievements do matter, but
only if you do them right.
Watch out for some of
the most common traps.
Keep your leaderboards clean.
Get a script to
do it if you can.
You're going to have
enough people playing
that I think automating
the process is
kind of the right solution here.
Watch out for
multi-player variants.
They can divide your
player pool to a point
where you don't have enough
good players to match
your players with.
And again, if you're playing
a real time multi-player game,
add a quick match button.
Get people into a game
as fast as they can.
So that's it.
Thank you very much for sitting
through the whole presentation.
Wow, good for you.
If you have any
comments, any questions,
go ahead and add them in the
comments right below here.
I do read them, and sometimes
I even respond to them.
And go ahead and
follow me on G+.
I'm right there.
That's it.
Thank you very
much for watching.
And I will see you next time.